the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
this is the second time we are having
this class we had it last year in a
smaller version
that was for six units of credit
and we had it once a week
and mostly
practitioners from the industry from
morgan stanley talking about examples
how math is applied in modern finance
okay
is it okay yeah and uh so we got some
good response last year so with the
support of the math department we
decided to expand
this class to
be 12 units of credit and have twice a
week so we have every tuesday and
thursday afternoon from 2 30 to 4 as you
know in this classroom
and
so last year dr
vasily estrella and i i'm by the way i'm
jake shaw and that's dr vasily and we
were the main instructors last year now
we doubled it up to four main
instructors
uh that's dr peter campston
and dr chong bong lee
the reason we doubled up the main
instructors is we have newly added math
lectures
mostly focusing on
from linear algebra probability to
statistics and some stochastic calculus
so give you the foundation to understand
the mass
will be used in those
examples
uh in the lecture taught by
the practitioners from the industry
and the purpose of this course is really
to give you a sampling manual to see
how mathematics is applied
in modern finance and help you to decide
if this is a field that you would be uh
okay you heard that
and uh
so hopefully this will give you enough
information to decide this is the field
you like to pursue in your future career
in fact last year
when we finished the class we had a few
students
coming
to work in the industry some worked at
morgan stanley someone worked at
elsewhere
and
so that's that's really the goal and uh
at the same time obviously you will
further solidify your math knowledge and
learn on
a new content and we put the
pre-requisite uh about the math part a
bit later
uh so i will use today's first lectures
time to give you an introduction really
to prepare you
some basic background knowledge about
the financial markets
um some terminologies will be used which
you may not have heard before
so before i get into the introduction i
mean i always like to know who are
actually in the classroom so let me ask
you a few questions you just need to
raise your hands and so i know roughly
what kind of background and uh where you
are
so how many undergraduate students are
here
so i would say
eighty percent okay statistics that's a
how many graduate students are here just
to verify
okay yeah that's about right 20
and uh how many students are in finance
and business major
just one okay and how many of you are in
math major
most of you okay how many of you are
engineering major
okay i feel
how many of you actually are from uh uh
other universities so
okay great because last year we had
quite a few so i want to specifically
tell you that you're very welcome to
attend the classes here right so it's
open door and
last year i remember we had a couple of
students from harvard
that's where i actually work right now
and
but uh my um
i forgot to mention that even that but
i'm affiliated with both the math
department and the sloan school here so
um
so anyway thanks for that we will be
doing a bit more polling along the way
mainly to get feedback of
how you feel about the class
last year we had it online so if you
feel the class is going too fast or the
math part is going too slow or the
finance part is a bit confusing
and the easiest way is really just to
send us emails and which you will find
from the class website
so anyway today
yes yeah we all have mit emails which
are listed on the website
yep and uh
obviously we have offices here you can
easily
stop by peter and june boone's offices
and
vasily and i probably will be
less often on campus but we'll be here
quite often and definitely love to be
more
so anyway i will start
today's lecture with a story
and the quiz at the end
don't worry it's not a real quiz i'm
just going to ask you some questions you
can raise your hand and
give your answer but let me start with
uh
my story this is actually my personal
story uh
i i want to tell you why i tell the
story later but the story actually was
in the mid 90s
i just left
solomon brothers that was my first
financial industry job
to go to morgan stanley in new york
to join the options trading desk
so the first day i sat down
i opened the trading book
i found something was missing
and
so i turned around i asked my desk quant
i said
where is the vega report okay so
let me show you
so that's the story so
and
i'm obviously not going to tell you the
story of pi or life of pi right that's
not a financial
story or the rest of the story alpha
beta delta gamma theta which you'll
learn from
peter and chumbo and varsity's classes
so i'm going to talk about vega so
so by the way before i tell you the
story what's unique about vega on this
list
it's not a greek letter that's right
okay so i turned around asking mike
that's quan as where's the vega report
but how many of you actually know what
vega
is
okay a lot of people know so anyway i'm
not gonna
it's just for the people who haven't
heard about before is a measurement
about a book or portfolio or position
sensitivity to volatility right so what
is the volatility which again you will
learn more in the rigorous terms
what's how it's defined in mathematics
but
the meaning of it is really a
measurement or indication of how
volatile or what's the standard
deviation of a price can change over
time okay just that's all you need to
know right now
i'm not going to ask you questions later
so
my desktop look at me said
you know this is supposed to be options
trading desk so he looked at me kind of
puzzled so instead of answering my
question he handed over me a
training manual for new employees
and new analysts
so i opened the trading training manual
and looked it through
i actually found my answer so actually
at the moment stanley this is not called
a vega it's called kappa
so now remember it's called a kappa
kappa is actually greek letter
so
further i look at on the same page there
was actually a footnote
which i copied down
so the footnote about
why it's called kappa
at the
at morgan stanley
kappa is also called vega by some
uneducated traders at the solomon
brothers
that's where i came from i just joined
they have mistaken vega as a greek
letter after gambling at vegas
so
anyway so that was my first day so
obviously i learned how to uh
call kappa very quickly because i came
from solomon brothers
and uh
i called kappa in the last 17 years
but you will hear people calling the
vega obviously probably more people
counting the vega
but anyway
so that's my first day at moon stanley
but why did i tell you this story right
what point i try to make
so this story is actually
when you think about it
mathematical or quantitative finance is
that rather new field a lot of these
terms were newly introduced
and the pricing model of options as you
know
right was introduced
in at the black shows in the 70s or some
of the groundwork maybe down bit earlier
but
it's not like
finance was a quantitative profession to
start with
so what we witnessed in the last 30
years was really a transformation
of trade of the trading profession
coming from
mostly
undereducated traders
some of them typically joined the firms
in the mail room
and became trader later on that's
typical career path
and to nowadays if you walk on the
trading floor you look at the trade you
talk to the traders most of them have
advanced degrees
and quite a few of them have
very you know
high training in mathematics and
computer science
so what has changed over the last 20 or
30 years
i mean i myself personally
you know was probably one of the data
points
experiencing this change
and
you know
i
certainly didn't expect i will be doing
this when i was at mit but i did that in
the last
you know 20 years
so
the point i'm trying to tell you is
before you dive into any details of
mathematics
or
any concept in finance in this class
just bear in mind
this is a field developed in the last
mostly 30 years
or even shorter and what you really need
to ask questions is
it's not really
is the right or wrong in mathematics is
it right or wrong in physics
so how the concepts are established
or
defined and verified because this is a
field the transformation about
the participants
products models methodology everything
are changing very rapidly even nowadays
still changing
so
with that
i will
give you some background of how the
financial markets
are actually started and that's really
the history part of this uh
this industry
so when we talk about markets we know in
early days right people need to exchange
goods you have something i don't have i
have something you don't have so
there's exchanges right then it becomes
centralized
there are stock exchanges futures
exchanges all over the world
then products will be listed as
securities on these exchanges
that's one way of trading which is
centralized
obviously in the last 10 15 years now we
have ecns electro
electronic platforms trade over you know
even larger volume of those trades
so financial products is
really just one form of trading and when
you think about i mean there are many
other ways of trading
aside from
exchanges one of them which is called
otc
is over the counter meaning
two counterparties agree to do a trade
without really subject to the exchange
rules or
the underlying trading agreement
does not have to be
a securitize the product or standardized
or you know whatever ways you defined it
and the different regions have different
exchanges and markets as well
and they typically specialize in local
products local company stocks
local
bonds and local currencies
so there are many different
forms so
again what's in common that's the
question you need to ask also you don't
know the specifics
and the currencies money itself also
traded
right so and that's where different the
uh currencies issued by different
countries
so when we talk about trading stocks
also people trade baskets of stocks
trade groups of stocks together and
that's stock
index or indices
so that there are different products now
how the stock gets listed on the stock
exchange
they go through ipo initial public
offering process
so when a company
changes from private to public it goes
through this ipo process it's called
primary market primary listing
and
once the stock is listed on exchange
and it becomes traded in the market we
call it secondary trading so that's not
that after the primary market
and the equity or stock is one form of
trading or one form of financial
products
what are other forms
loans
actually that products are more generic
than equity products
when you started
thinking about what is really the what
is really finance is about it's really
about
someone has money someone doesn't
someone has money to land out someone
needs to borrow money
so that's loan
loan is really a private agreement
between two counterparties or multiple
counterparties
when you securitize them it becomes
bonds
and uh
when you look at bonds every government
right issue large sovereign debt the u.s
government has
large outstanding u.s treasury
debt bonds notes bills
and corporates
have issued a lot of that
product as well they borrow money when
they need to build a new factory or
expand
universities borrow money right when mit
needs to build a new building
you know some of the money will make
come from the endowment support some
will come from
you know some other form of research
budget or some will come from you know
that financing right just borrow from
the public
local governments states right counties
even right so they have various forms
so that's that product commodities
actually you know metal energy
agriculture uh products or traded right
mostly in the futures format and some in
physical format meaning you take
deliveries
when you actually
buy and sell you build a warehouse to
take them your you know ship
tanks
right to store above the ocean
and the real estates you buy and sell
houses you know
2008 financial crisis if you read about
it
this has a lot to do with the real
estate market the mortgages
and asset-backed securities
and
so i'm not trying to give you all the
definition dumping the information on
you but i like you at least you're
hearing at once today
and then you have more interest you can
read on the side
so asset-backed securities is when you
have an asset
you basically
issue a debt
with the asset
backing it
and
how how do you rate the assets
risk level and what's the income stream
cash flow
and
during before 2008 financial crisis
as you heard large amount of cmbs
commercial
basically is a commercial real estate
backed uh
you know securities mortgage securities
and the residential as well
and further of all these you heard
probably a lot about the derivative
products
so that started with swaps options
and the structured products you become
more tailor-made
for either investors or
borrowers
to structure the products in a way to
suit their needs and
some of the the complexity of those
structured products
you know become quite high
and the mathematics involved in pricing
them and the risk management become
rather challenging
so
let me
coming back to the players in the market
one large sector of player one large
type of player is really
bank
so there are
essentially after 1933 uh glass-steagall
uh legislation
there were two main types of banks one
is called commercial bank the other is
investment bank
commercial bank
is supposedly
you're taking deposits and lend out the
money
and
doing you know more commercial services
investment bank supposed to focus on the
capital markets
raising capital
trading and
asset management but obviously after
1999
there's a you know the glass-steagall
was
repealed right there's no longer
that some people blame that and probably
for a very good reason
for the cause of 2008
financial crisis
but
i want to tell you how current the
investment banks are organized so i mean
vasily just mentioned he works in a
fixed income right
and
so banks typically organized by you know
institutional business and asset
management so within the institutional
client business it has
typically three main parts
fixed income which trade
the debt and the derivative products
equity trade stocks and the derivative
products
and ibd stands for investment banking
division which
really covers corporate finance raising
capital
listing a stock ipo and merger and
acquisition
and advisory
so that's that's how banks are organized
outside banks
other players basically the asset
managers are obviously a very big force
in the financial markets
so the question a lot of people ask is
is this a zero-sum game right i'm sure
you you heard this many times
so in the financial markets some people
win some people lose
i mean a lot of times
it depends on specific products you
trade
the market you're in it is a lot of
times you know
pretty net zero but why
why do we need financial markets right
i mean this this comes back
to what i described before
because something existed actually
there's a need for it it's really the
need to bridge
between
the lenders and the borrowers
that's really coming down to the
essential relationship
so investors who have money
need have better yield or better return
better interest in the current
environment when you have a savings
account you know you don't really earn
much at all
and so you would
have to
take more risk
to generate more return or you have a
longer horizon
cds or other type of products or trade
stocks right so that's when somebody has
money when you trade stocks you're
essentially
you know you're buying a stock you give
the money somewhere
supposedly you know go to the company
the company use the money uh you know to
generate a better return
and for the borrowers
whoever needs money
they
need to have access to the capital right
so they
obviously
different borrowers have different risks
some people borrow money never return
right so or never generate any returns
or never even return the principle
and
so the trade between lenders and the
borrowers is again essentially the main
driver of the financial markets
so a few more words about market
participants
so banks and so-called dealers play the
role of market making
what is market making
so when you or some
end user go to the market wants to buy
or sell
you typically if there's no market you
don't really find the match and some of
the the products you want to buy or sell
may not necessarily be liquid
so the dealers step in the middle make
your price say okay you want to buy or
sell
i can tell you you know
this stock i make your price
you know 99
cents and
that's my bid 95 cents that's my offer
right so that's the price i'm willing to
buy or sell
so that's called they but what the
result of the trade the dealer actually
takes the other side of your trade so
they take
principal risk in this case
so that's the difference between dealers
and the brokers so brokers don't really
take principal
risks if you want to buy some buy
something or sell something if i'm a
broker
so i don't make your price i go to the
market makers
i actually put two
people together to kind of a matchmaking
make that trade happen
so i earned a commission so that's a
broker's role
so obviously there are individual
investors retail investors same meaning
mutual funds who actually manage
public investors money typically in a
long only
format
meaning their loan means you buy
something so you don't really
sure sell a particular
security
insurance companies has large asset they
need to generate return generate cash
flow to meet the liability
needs
so they need to invest
and the pension funds same thing as
inflation goes higher they need to pay
out more to the retirees so where do you
get a return right sovereign wealth fund
similarly endowment funds they all have
this
same situation have capital needs to
deploy and make better return
so there's other type of
players hedge funds
so
how many of you have heard hedge funds
okay good almost everyone okay so i'm
not the and peter mentioned he used to
work at a hedge fund so
and
um so there are
different types of strategies which i
will dive into a bit more but hedge fund
played a role in the market
they basically find opportunities to
profit from
inefficient
market positioning or pricing right so
they have different strategies
and the private equity i mean different
type of funds they basically look to
take a pr
invest in companies
and uh
you know either take them private or
invest in the private uh equity forum
to hopefully improve the company's
profitability and then catch up
and governments obviously have a huge
impact on the market
so
we know in the financial crisis
government intervened
and not only that
at the normal market condition
government always have a very large
impact on the market because they are
the policy makers they decide the
interest rate and interest rate curve
and the different policies they push out
obviously will generate
different outlook for the future markets
therefore profitability
then the corporate hedges and the
liabilities when corporates borrow money
they create some risk so they
need to be sensitive to the market
changes
so to summarize
the types of trading
the first type
is really just hedging that means you're
not proactively adding risk
to what you have you already have some
exposure let's say
just give you an example let's say you
borrow money you bought a house you have
mortgage
and uh
so
let's say it's a you know uh floating
rate mortgage payments
and you're worried about the interest
rate going higher right so you can
lock that rate in into the fixed rate
format
or you can find ways to
to hedge your exposure
or your corporate has a large income
coming from europe
so you have euros coming in but you're
not sure
if euro will trade stronger to the u.s
dollar
in the future or trade weaker right if
you trade it will be if you think it
will be stronger you just leave it but
if you think it will
will trade weaker so you may want to
hedge it meaning you want to sell euro
and buy us dollars
and so that's the hedging type the
second type as i mentioned is a market
maker so market maker also takes
principle risk but the main source of
profit is really to earn the bid offer
i gave you the example of 90 cents a bit
95 cents offer so that's what the
market maker is trying to
profit from but obviously they have
residual risks sitting on the book not
every trade is matched
so
how to optimize
those group of trades
that's what market maker is doing
most of the banks dealers are market
makers i mean in the new um
regulation obviously proprietary trading
is
some you know expand right
and so the third type is really the
proprietary trader the risk taker
so these are the hedge funds or some
portfolio managers they need to focus on
generating return
and with control the risk
so that's where the beta and offer the
concept comes in so if you're a
portfolio manager
i mean some people say you don't really
you know don't worry don't go pick any
stocks just by s p 500 index fund you
know very cheap you can
pay very little cost to do it that's
true so but if you want to beat the s p
500 index
let's assume we call it s
p 500 index fund is
asset b so the return of that off b
that's the return of that index
then you have a portfolio a
you
you time series of return of you asset a
obviously you can do linear regression
by your a lot of your math major here
and you can find a correlation
between those two time series
so that how the two returns are are
related in a simplified form
so you can say
this actually somehow it came out it's
supposed to be alpha and a beta but it
turned out to be uh you know
the the letters but so in the short
description beta is really kind of you
know just think as uh
the correlated move with the the other
asset alpha is really the the you know
the difference in return
uh
it's a format you want to beat smp 500
so you want
basically have certain tracking of this
index but you want to return more on top
of that
so
let me just go in
details of how each type of trade
actually occurs
so when we talk about hedging i
mentioned the currency example let me
give you another example
a lot of people issue bonds or issue
debt so this example i'm going to give
you is
let's think about australian
corporate
because
interest rate in australia is higher
than in japan
so typically people like to
borrow money
in japan because you pay
smaller interest
and you invest it in australia you earn
higher
interest rate
so
let me ask you a question
who can tell me why don't people just do
that all day long just borrow from japan
and invest
in
australia
then that interest rate i'm giving you
an example of a difference
is about three and a half percent for
the ten year roughly you know ten years
uh swap rates
why don't yeah go ahead
right
because you invest in the australia
aussie right australian dollar the
australian dollar may become weaker to
the yen you may lose all your profit or
even more right
and further if everybody
plays the same game then and when you
try to exit you
you have the adverse impact of your
trade
so let's say you you think that's the
right time to do it but then
at one time you wake up you said huh i
think too many people are doing this i
want to hedge myself so what do you do
yep so you try to lock in right so
basically you
you sell the australian dollars
by the japanese yen
or on the interest rate terms you say
you you basically pay
the house australian dollar in the swap
lag and the receive yen
so that in the you this involves foreign
exchange trade
interest rate swap
and the cross currency swap
so your answer about
currency forward is roughly right but it
obviously involves a bit more in actual
execution
so let's just give you an example even
you are not a finance guy
you know you work in a corporate you
just do
input export or building a factory or
you know you have to know actually
what the exposure is so risk management
nowadays
becomes pretty widespread responsibility
it's not just of you know the corporate
treasury's responsibility
so that's on the hedging side obviously
if you're um
intel for example
right you sell a lot of chips uh
overseas
and your income actually intel does have
a lot of overseas income sitting outside
the states
so the exposure to them is if
the exchange rate fluctuates dollar
becomes a lot stronger they actually
lose money
so they need to think about you know how
to hatch the revenue produced overseas
and uh
obviously if you are import exporters
that's even more apparent
and
if you're in entering the merger deal
you one company is buying another
you need to hedge
your potential currency exposure and
your interest rate exposure and whatever
is on
on the
on assets or the liability of the
balance sheet you need to have your
exposure
so we talked about the hedging activity
let's talk about a bit of market making
so
if it's a simple transparent product
everybody pretty much knows where the
price is right so if you buy apple stock
i think a lot of people know
pretty much what it is you may even have
it on your cell phone right know where
that stock is
but
if it's not transparent
so what do you do so if i instead of
asking you where apple is probably
you're going to tell me 4.95 today
okay
yeah but if i ask you instead what is
the call option on
apple stock in the you know two months
time
i'll give you a strike let's say 500.
right so you're probably less
transparent so that
market maker comes in to provide that
liquidity
and then takes the risk they manage the
book by balancing those greeks
which i mentioned earlier delta which
describes
the kind of the linear
relationship of this whole book to the
underlying stock or underlying whatever
currency that's called the delta
gamma is really
the change
of
the portfolio take the derivative
to the to the delta or to the underlying
spot so that's
the second order derivative right the
delta is the first order so gamma you
take so now you have
curvature or convexity coming in
and theta is really
you know on nothing changes in the
market nothing changes in your position
how your
trading book is
carrying or bleeding away money
and we talk about the volatility
exposure with vega and on top of that
what are the tail risks you know how do
what other events can actually get you
into big trouble right
so people use value at risk so you will
hear this var concept in some of the
lectures and which is also obviously a
very important concept and i think peter
will uh or tumor would probably peter
will teach
uh
then
capital right uh how much capital you're
using it becomes a very important issue
nowadays
and balance sheet
again you have asset your liability how
how do you leverage how much leverage
you have before the crisis for example a
lot of the banks leverage up 40 times
meaning when you have one dollar you
have a 40 exposure so when the market
moves a little you get wiped out that's
that's really what amplified in the 2008
financial crisis
and how do you measure
the the asset in balance sheet when you
have derivatives right rather than
straightforward notional
so a lot of quantitative type of people
like to focus a bit more on the risk
taking side because
people heard stories about the
successful cases of some hedge funds
using high math right they generate very
impressive returns
uh they seem to have an edge so a lot of
people focus on trading strategies right
so that that's that falls into the
category of
proprietary trading or risk taking so
that you can just simply doing
directional trading strategies just go
long or sure the stock right that's very
simple you know they are the so-called
gut traders gut feeling go with your gut
you don't even think he said i'm eating
i'm eating um
you know uh curry today so i i go long
i'm eating rice tomorrow so i go short
so this arbitrage arbitrage is really to
find
the relationships between
prices
and try to profit from uh
those relationship uh missed pricing
this is actually very interesting
this um not many people focus on
arbitrage you know because when a lot of
people are gut traders you essentially
just watch your own market you don't
really care what's going on if you trade
gold uh in the states
i mean obviously
the gold prices happen in asia and in
europe
matters right so you because you're
trading the same thing if they're not
priced the same way you can profit from
the difference
and uh
that's just a simple example but
a spot price versus forward price that's
a deterministic relationship it's a
mathematical relationship if that
relationship breaks down you can also
profit so there are many examples of
mathematical relationship which gives
you the arbitrage opportunity
i mean the other type is called value
trade or relative value strategies you
instead of
you know think there's a deterministic
temporary mathematical relationship you
look at the longer term in horizon
trying to determine what is really the
underlying value of a particular
instrument
then trade on the relative value
obviously there are successful value
investors out there
and the systematic trader
builds computer models
one example is train the following right
so just follow the price trend
i mean that used to be a effective
uh strategy
for some time but when a lot of people
doing the same thing that becomes much
less effective
or momentum same things stat up right
finding statistics
statistical relationship among
large number of stocks
then you know trade
at the higher frequency
and fundamental analysis you're really
trying to understand what's going on in
the world what is the
trade balance what is the earning
potential of a you know of a company
what's the trade balance of a country
what is the policy change what does it
mean when federal reserve announced
they're going to taper the quantitative
easing
right what's why stock market sold off
in the last
couple months
especially why stocks in india
brazil indonesia sold out more
right why is that so you know it goes
through those fundamental analysis
uh and there are special situations some
companies are going through
uh particular
uh difficulties assets are priced very
cheaply so there are firms out there i
mean you probably heard you know
bain capital and many others right they
focus on these private equity and
special situation opportunities
so
what has what have all these to do with
mathematics right
where does math come in
how do you use math
so i want to give you some aspects of
that so from my personal experience
i joined the market really started
working on pricing models so that's the
first area
so math is very effective because when
you
your bank your or your corporate
you want to buy some financial
instruments you have to know
where is the price
it's easy to observe a stock in the
market but when it comes to
more complex products they just take one
step
full or forward on the complexity which
is option you have to know how to press
an option so that's where the math comes
in right you actually have to be able to
solve differential equations to get a
you know model price then you obviously
adjust to the your assumptions to fit
into the market
so pricing model which
uh
vasily and many of his colleagues can
tell you more which is very much
a very interesting and challenging area
how do you price all these instruments
and when i say pricing it's not in the
narrow definition of just coming up as a
price when you build a pricing model you
also generate the risk parameters of
these
instruments and how do you risk manage
them
so that comes the second part
so math is very useful in risk
management
which i will give you some uh
another quiz questions after this slide
when you can see that
risk management itself is very
challenging it's not a purely
mathematical question but yet math plays
a very important role to quantify
how much exposure you have then the
third is trading strategies
again i think a lot of people with mass
background
or
in general people are looking for
the so-called holy grail
trading strategies
just almost like perpetual motion
machines right people looking for 100
years ago you just turn it on it makes
money by itself you go to sleep you go
on vacation you come back you have more
in your bank account
obviously that's not going to happen
the robe the robo trader a
robotic trader
is the dream
it has its place or its use but it's a
fast
evolving market you have to constantly
you know
upgrade your research
and uh
adjust your strategies
there's no such thing
you can build and leave it alone it runs
for itself forever but
i just want to mention that because
maybe
towards the end of the term you will
feel i came up with this brilliant
trading strategy i think it's going to
make money forever please let me know
first
so
um i want to leave some time
to
vasily actually he
he can give you some examples of
projects of last year's students who
actually
came to this class and did some real
application at morgan stanley but before
i hand over to vasily let me ask you
some questions i just want to
give not really to quiz you just give
you the sense
how
math
and intuition and judgment can come into
the same place
so let me first give you examples i call
risk aversion
so you you are facing two choices choice
a and choice b
choice a b you have 80 chance to lose
500
you have
20
chance to win five hundred dollars
it's pretty clear right that's it that's
choice a
well choice b
you basically just lock in you have 100
chance to lose 280 dollars
let me ask you
for
whoever likes to choose
a choice a please raise your hand
about six out of
say let's call it the 50. okay
so can i ask you why you think choice a
makes sense so i know it's a lower
expected value but i
i just kind of enjoy
right
because you don't want to lock in that
280
loss right that way you still have 20
chance to win
so okay
uh for the wines raise the hand for
choices are there any other reasons
same reason
okay
okay i assume the rest of you will
choose choice b unless you neither okay
how many of you choose choice b
okay choice b okay and are they anybody
think neither is right so maybe
you have no you have to choose okay
no you have to choose okay so either
choice a or choice b
so
let me just talk a little bit about this
again i'm not trying to tell you which
one is right but let's just share my
thoughts how to look at these why i call
risk aversion right so this is a very
common
human behavior when you go to the market
you buy a stock
when the stock goes up makes big money
the natural tendency for especially
someone is new to the market is to let's
take take profit let's sell oh i made a
thousand dollars i made five hundred
dollars let's go you know have a nice
meal or you know whatever i buy a
ipad
but when the stock loses money what's
the natural tendency
that's
i think natural tendency a lot of people
will keep it i think if you have the
discipline to get out that's great and
that's you know i
i mean trading is really all about how
where do you how do you risk manage you
know have a discipline and how to manage
your losses
right the natural tendency a lot of
people say well i think there's a chance
20 chance to come back i'm going to make
500 more right why do i want to lock in
to stop myself out at 280
right so even though the expected value
as a lot of people
i think a lot of people said you know
you lose expected value which is three
hundred dollars in choice a
but
you would still
you know not to choose choice b because
they're unlocking the 280 loss again i'm
not
trying to
inject the idea to you of which one is
right or wrong but think about it right
so that's really the common behavior
which
mathematically may not make sense but
that's a lot of people still would like
to do right
and also really when you think about it
was
depends on your situation
and uh
if you can
let's say you think the market i mean
i'll give you the stock example again
if you're not purely following the
discipline of stop loss but you just
think
you know the fundamental picture has
changed you really don't think the stock
is should go up anymore
obviously at whatever level you should
get out right
regardless how much loss you're locking
and uh but if you if you think the
fundamental story is still very sound
you should think about
as if you don't have a position what do
you want to do next
so but anyway mathematically i just want
to see it's actually
i think
i guess this is mit
so many people think mathematically you
know you would
actually
choose choice b because that's low
expectation which makes sense but i
think if you ask
a larger audience i think you probably a
lot of people don't really want to
choose choice b because they don't want
locking the loss
now let me change the question
a little bit
so choice a becomes instead of
the 80 chance to lose now you have 80
chance to win
500 and 20 chance to lose 500
choice b you have 100 chance
to win 280
who chooses who would choose choice a
again minority of this audience let's
say less than 10 percent okay who would
choose choice b
the rest of it okay
all
right um
can someone uh choose choice a give me a
argument why would you yeah um
okay
yep
anyone wants to give me a reason for
choice b
higher shop
yep
okay
well
let me just leave it here again
i think
we can talk a bit more along in the
class i mean the last day of the class
hopefully we have much deeper discussion
on this
it's not unique the answer okay i think
it can go either way i mean as as you
said if your bank account balance
is
let's say you're a freshman student your
bank account is uh
uh
eight hundred dollars
your choice will be very different from
someone has
a hundred thousand dollars in his bank
account
okay
and uh
also your risk tolerance right how much
you can
you can tolerate
but
i'm not going to give you say this is
right or wrong but with that let me
move on and give you some homework
so before i give you the homework i want
to make a few more comments
so do people always learn from the
experiences you think you know in
science right we collect evidence we
build models
we first understand the physics we build
mathematic models then we verify in
physics doing experiments
but is that the same
investigation process process in finance
i mean market cycles are typically very
long but people tend to have show the
memories is so how do people really
learn from the experience it's a very
interesting question and the very
natural tendency is to extrapolate
historical experience
what happened in 2008 people still
remember
what happened in
1970s maybe some people still remember
what happened 100 years ago right so
people tend to
extrapolate join conclusions from very
recent experience
and
deterministic relationship versus
statistical relationship is
very interesting as well when you try to
trade on those how do you really build
models
i mean is the market really efficient
right i mean
what is really
what part is efficient you know how do
you really apply those theories
in your day-to-day
uh risk management or training
activities
and sometimes people tend to
oversimplify right just say oh i can
model this you know this is one
important parameter i just take that
so i just give you all the warnings that
again very
young new
field and
largely often this is art than science
so keep that in mind even though we're
talking about
mathematics in finance math is very
powerful and useful in finance so learn
the math learn the finance first but
keep those questions along the way when
you are learning during this class
okay so suggested the homework optional
just
i mentioned a lot of terminologies
uh today go to the course website read
what we have put up
for the financial glossary right so if
you still have things you don't
understand make compile your own list
of financial concepts which you can
search on the web
or even ask us
but i encourage you to do that it will
prepare you well so that's really
uh and the read other materials on the
on the course web
so we got uh
maybe how about this we still got about
15 minutes or 10 or 12 minutes left so i
passed it to vasili now maybe we can
leave five minutes for some questions
yeah okay yeah
just mention that that apple trade is
now at 494.4
when you were saying it was at 88.
all right
so
yeah just a couple examples well first
of all
no offense to
a few people who wear
who wear
but
i just wanted to to give
an example of uh
yeah thanks
because he was working in in our group
and it just will give you an idea of
what uh
what a little bit of an idea what what
we will be talking about and what
actually we do in the daily life or
uh what an intern or somebody who comes
to work in this industry could do
and
one project is
which tushan
worked was
on estimating uh the noisy derivative
the derivative is called delta delta is
usually a first derivative to a function
and
as we'll see in the class quite often to
to obtain a price you
you do it through monte carlo meaning
running a lot of pass and then averaging
along along them so it is statistical
methods so obviously there there is a
noise to
to your answer every time
so if you want to
to differentiate
this function and get the derivative
uh then this derivative will be quite
noisy
and so instead of getting the the true
derivative you might obtain something
quite different from two derivative just
because there is a confidence interval
around any any point and obviously there
is a trade-off here as well because
you can run more paths throw more
computational power
and
which will reduce your confidence
interval you you will know uh
better where where you are more precise
uh or
the other uh
solution could be if you know that your
your function is not too concave and
reasonably flat you might
move uh the uh
do the numerical
differentiation on wider interval
basically reducing the significance of
the error right and you would hope to
arrive to
a better approximation so obviously
there is somewhere balance and the
question was
uh how uh is there an optimal
shift size
to obtain to to get
the derivative
and
that's what oh
oh oh
the slight good corrupted
right uh so the oh there was a quite a
bit of mathematics involved and
minimization and optimization
there was an answer and
that's actually
what we
finally
arrived at
and that's some
some two example but still it shows you
that if you use constant size and
not optimal size that that would be your
numerical derivative of this of this
blue function while the uh
while if you use the optimal shift size
which which duration computed it would
be much
smoother and much better
so that's one example uh
and that's what he did and we actually
are implementing it in our systems and
plan uh plan to use it
in in practice
another project
uh was actually quite different
and it was about electronic trading and
basically
uh how to
better predict prices
of uh of cro of currencies
and exchange rate
funny enough it was on ruble uh ruble us
dollar because it was
actually aimed for for our
moscow office
uh and um
basically what we had we had the noisy
observation of broker data uh and they
it it was not it was coming on a
different non
uh
on uniform times basically at random
times
so uh we decided to use kalman filter
and um to uh
and uh to study how
it can predict
and yeah that's one of uh
of the nice
graphs dusan produced
which which again uh will be we will use
this the strategy and this the column
filters which he constructed
in our
in our e-trading
platform
in moscow
all right so uh
that's just a couple of examples which i
wanted to give you and as a preview what
we will be talking in the class
uh
they uh just remind so the website is
fully functional
uh i put syllable we put syllables there
a a short list of literature
uh the we will be posting a lot of
materials there uh
most probably mostly
most lectures will be published there
jake's slides are there already
so uh any
questions uh handbag uh there's some
signup sheets right so we like to get
your emails so we can
uh put you on the website for the
further announcements but you can also
you know add yourself yes i believe but
it's probably easier if you put your
email on the signup sheet so we can uh
yeah but but please please visit and and
sign up yeah because there will be
announcements to the class
all right thank you very much